maybe sunlight really is the best
disinfectant
uh and i don't know much more than
you sent me a link to this
article zachary sunlight inactivates
coronavirus eight
times faster than predicted we need to
know why
and that links to this paper uvb
radiation alone may not explain sunlight
and activation of saris cov2
a paper that came out actually in
february of of this year
that finds basically the theoretical
underpinnings for why
um why it was start thought that sars
kobe 2 was not transmitting as
i guess was not transmitting and was not
there for manifesting his covet and
people who were outdoors was
largely based on a model around uvc i
think
deactivating um deactivating the virus
but
the empirical evidence that's come in
since those early theoretical
predictions
um says actually no there's going to be
a lot more going on
this virus is just unable to persist
out in sunlight for very long at all and
um you know we're not gonna
we're not gonna go inside baseball here
on on you know all the reasons all of
the disconnects
um but it's fabulous news like there is
not a variant
yet that we have heard of sorry's kobe 2
um for which this is not true that is to
say which does
not um deactivate in sunlight which
means that the advice that we've been
giving from the very beginning
go outside spend time outside and you
know and
you know do you do not need to wear a
mask outside unless you're jammed
together
holds and is you know is even it's
important for mental health it's
important for physical health it's
important at just about every level
possible
yes and uh so i want to recap a little
bit about what we've said
a sars v2 does not appear to transmit
outdoors
that could be a purely uv light or
sunlight more generally
based phenomenon but it isn't it doesn't
appear to transmit outdoors at night
either
right so that's really important what
that means is that you've got
at least two mechanisms and that
what it results in is at least for the
time being
that we have a loophole in the
constraints that come
from sars kobe 2 especially when the
weather is hospitable and meeting
outdoors as possible
and we should be taking full advantage
of that you wanted to say something
uh well hold on um
i mean one obvious second explanation
and i suspect it'll be
more than two is that it is well
understood that this like i don't know
maybe all but certainly many and i think
most uh viruses and other pathogens are
effectively density dependent
and so outside where there is airflow
and where you're constantly blowing away
boundary layers
and um you know the virus is you know
heading up into the atmosphere as
opposed to staying in the room where you
are
is going to be effective at effectively
dispersing
the virus well we know this to be the
case the question is is that the
mechanism that makes
uh night safe outdoors
it is unlikely that that is completely
the explanation i said i said
one one clear hypothesis that i would
say i can't imagine that this isn't true
i just wanted to name the two that we
definitely know are true
volume and air flow reduces the density
of particles that one interacts with and
that that has a highly protective effect
and we know that
uv light disables the virus and maybe
sunlight does so more generally than
just its uv component
why is an interesting question whether
this interacts with the question of
where
uh sarsko v2 came from if it was
laboratory in origin obviously
uh laboratories are not drenched in
sunlight they are drenched in artificial
light
of course the fact that the virus
ultimately comes from bats
whether it was modified in the lab or
not does suggest it would not interact
terribly frequently in daylight as bats
are all nocturnal so anyway there's a
lot of questions that could be
uh addressed but a
could it evolve to be transmitted
outdoors it could so we should be
cautious outdoors though not overly so
um but for the moment it is apparently
the answer to
how to keep things functional um
during a time when you can't afford to
do certain normal things like uh
you know go to a concert um so
in any case that's uh it is an important
finding
and it is important for us to continue
to track whether or not that changes but
the fact that no variant yet
has has figured out how to transmit
outdoors is great news
it sure is
you